[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be once
again discussing everyone's favorite
lady in pink
dolores umbridge dolores umbridge was a
cruel
twisted woman who took pleasure in the
administration of law and order
in her mind the ministry of magic an
institution to which she had devoted
most of her life
could do no wrong and their final word
ran supreme
there were no ifs ands or buts when it
came to questioning the word of the
ministry
after all they upheld wizarding law and
they knew best
umbridge first comes to prominence in
the order of the phoenix
when her and fudge spearheaded a
campaign with the goal of having
dumbledore removed
i said master of hogwarts and by the
time the 95-96 school year came around
the ministry of magic put out a
statement expressing that they were
unimpressed with the slipping standards
of hogwarts this statement was the
result of a fearful minister of magic
fudge lashing out he was blinded by fear
and in utter denial the dark lord
voldemort had returned
fudge was punishing dumbledore who was
so strongly trying to convince him of
the truth
and despite dumbledore's continuous
attempts to convince fudge of this truth
he was still eventually stripped of his
title and said master of hogwarts
in place of dumbledore the ministry of
magic of course appointed dolores
umbridge
who in that same school year worked as
the defense against the dark arts
professor
as well as the hogwarts high inquisitor
during her time at hogwarts
she had enormous power over the students
teachers curriculum
and grounds she made everyone's lives
miserable
however fortunately for everyone at
hogwarts umbridge's placement there was
short-lived
as it was later shown that voldemort had
in fact returned
fudge just needed to see it for himself
after the events of the order of the
phoenix
umbridge returned to the ministry of
magic conducting business as usual
and picking up where she left off
however by the time the deathly hallows
came around
dolores character had a few more
developments first of all she was now in
possession of salazar's lyrins locket
she received a locket as a bribe from
mundunga's fletcher and
though she had a particular affinity for
it had no idea of its magical properties
she didn't know that it once belonged to
salazarin himself
or that it was one of voldemort's
horcruxes and she was especially unaware
of the fact
that it influenced her actions and
affected her mind
the physical presence of a locket
however was still stunning which is what
drew umbridge to it in the first place
he looked at the serpentine s inlaid
with glittering
green stones it was easy to visualize it
as a minuscule snake
concentrating on the letter s imagining
a serpent while the contents of locket
rattled
like a trapped cockroach it would have
been easy to pity it
except that the cut around harry's neck
still burned the golden doors of the
locket swung wide with a little click
behind both of the glass windows within
blinked a living eye
dark and handsome as tom riddle's eyes
had been before he turned them scarlet
and slit pupilled the soul shard within
the locket exerted a negative energy
force on anyone in its proximity you see
which is why harry potter hermione
granger and ron weasley all became
irritable when it hung around their
necks
umbridge however embraced the locket
fully as she was already quite a
malicious character to begin with
umbridge who was already quite sinister
became increasingly more cutthroat with
a locket hanging around her neck
which led to her eventual placement in
the deathly hallows as head of the
mughal-born registration commission
the function of this commission was
absolutely ridiculous
the perfect absurd pairing with someone
like umbridge
the ministry of magic is undertaking a
survey of so-called
muggleborns the better to understand how
they came to possess
magical secrets recent research
undertaken by the department of
mysteries
reveals that magic can only be passed
from person to person
when wizards reproduce where no proven
wizarding ancestry exists
therefore the so-called muggleborn is
likely to have obtained
magical power by theft or force the
ministry is determined to root out
such usurpers of magical power and to
this end has issued an invitation to
every so-called muggleborn
to present themselves for interview
where the newly appointed mughal-born
registration commission
so what does umbridge's heritage look
like surely she must be confident in her
pure blood status
if she's heading such a commission right
in the following excerpt from the
deathly hallows
which shows a conversation between
hermione and umbridge she seems to
suggest
that she's related to a pureblood family
that's
that's pretty dolores she said pointing
at the pendant gleaming in the ruffled
folds of umbridge's blouse
what snapped umbridge glancing down oh
yes
an old family heirloom she said patting
the locket lying on her large bosom
the s stands for selwyn i am related to
the selwyns
indeed there are few pureblood families
to whom i am not related
and while she doesn't exactly make the
proclamation that she comes from the
selwyn family very confidently
is worth addressing the closest known
connection that we know to the selwyn
family
is a man only known as selwyn a british
pureblood dark wizard
and one of voldemort's death eaters
selwyn was present for most of battles
in the second wizarding war
and is even addressed by voldemort
directly during the battle of the seven
potters
you're one selwyn give me your wand
selwyn is certainly one of those
characters that flies under the radar
and while we don't know too much about
him we do know that he was involved with
the capturing of luna lovegood
and responsible for the subsequent
threats addressed to her father
xenophilius lovegood selwyn was not a
good man
he was an evil dark prejudiced death
eater
but was he really related to umbridge or
was that just a feeble attempt at
convincing hermione of her pure blood
status
claiming that she came from the selwyn
family seems like a bit of a large lie
just to justify her possession of the
locket so
is there possibly a real connection
there if we dig just a little bit into
dolores history
i think that we can quite easily refute
her claim from pottermore
dolores jane umbridge was the eldest
child and only daughter of orford
umbridge
a wizard and ellen cracknell a muggle
who also had a squib son
dolores parents were unhappily married
and dolores secretly despised both of
them
offered for his lack of ambition he had
never been promoted and worked in the
department of magical maintenance at the
ministry of magic
and her mother ellen for her flightiness
and tidiness
and muggle lineage both orford and his
daughter blamed ellen for dolores
brothers lack of magical ability
with the result that when dolores was 15
the family split down the middle
orford and dolores remaining together
and ellen vanishing back again into the
muggle world with her son
dolores never saw her mother or brother
again never spoke of either of them
and henceforth pretended to all she met
that she was a pure blood
one thing that i've always found
interesting is how umbridge established
herself
and got started in the ministry without
her identity ever being properly
questioned
in a world that had only just recently
begun to accept half-bloods and
muggle-borns
as part of their society it's curious
that umbridge got by the way that she
did
had she tried to enter the ministry a
century sooner it's untelling how that
would have gone for her
however it is revealed that those who
did passively question her identity
or her father's almost always had nasty
things
happen to them nasty things tended to
happen to people who asked about orford
or anything that dolores did not like
talking about
and people who wanted to remain on her
good side pretended to believe her
version of her ancestry
so why did she lie and say that she came
from the selwyn family
first of all i think that the apparent
jumpiness in her voice when questioned
about the locket
is totally indicative of a liar she's
currently serving as head of the
muggerborne registration commission
and i can't think of the worst time for
it to be surfaced that you're a
half-blood
additionally umbridge is very concerned
with her image
and she was likely almost overly keen to
convince everyone of her pure blood
status
whether she knew that the s stood for
slytherin or not is unclear
but she obviously felt compelled to make
some sort of connection between the s
and another pure blood wizarding family
and selwyn was just the first that came
to mind
could dolores be related to the subway
family somewhere in her lineage
possibly but is it likely i don't think
so
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard hi
[Music]
you